we are big on safety every tractor needs
it they come out of the factory too
light well except for the summit tx25
that comes standard with rim guard in
its rear tires rim guard is a non-toxic
non-corrosive beet juice byproduct it's
not going to freeze down you good to
minus 35 degrees Fahrenheit at 10.7
pounds per gallon that's the heaviest
natural liquid ballast on the market
today I love the fact that this is
invisible it's stored inside the tires
it's there all the time so if you forget
to put anything on your three-point
you're still going to be set up safely
rim guard liquid balls is going to help
keep you planted to the ground this
keeps you safe as an operator keeps you
more efficient when you're using your
front end loader and puts more power to
the ground when you need it now if you
don't have a summit tx25 and you need to
add rim guard to your tires you'll find
it at over a thousand dealers Nationwide
visit rimguardsolutions.com to find a
dealer near you
[Music]